- Hi, everyone.
Sal Khan here from the
not-for-profit Khan Academy
and I just wanted to
announce our first-ever
fundraising campaign on YouTube.
As you know, we are a
not-for-profit organization
and we are able to do the work we do
because of donations
from folks like yourself,
so we are trying to
raise $10000 on YouTube.
Every dollar is equal to three
hours of learning some place
on the planet.
This is learning for you,
learning for your family,
or learning for a young child
in some part of the world
that might not have resources otherwise.
So please donate by
clicking on the blue button
which is either there or there,
but you'll find it.
There should be a blue
button around me someplace,
and please support us on this mission
of a free, world-class education
for anyone, anywhere.
Thank you.